what's up it's Tuesday April 26 I'm Mary
and you're watching gamespot news whoops
looks like the next Call of Duty name
has been leaked it's going to be called
war forever I mean infinite warfare it's
like the same the next call of duty game
has a name and it's call of duty
infinite warfare according to what looks
like an accidental listing on the
PlayStation Store as discovered by a
Reddit user and verified by gamespot
browsing to the trending section of the
PlayStation Store on the ps4 reveals the
listing pictured here selecting the name
takes you to only a blank page but it's
still the first indication of what this
year's inevitable call of duty sequels
will be called Activision is yet to make
any announcements regarding the next
call of duty they probably didn't
appreciate this typically they announced
around May of each year so we assume
that'll be the case this time but since
we got the leak who knows the game will
be developed by infinity ward the
developer responsible for the modern
warfare games and most recently call of
duty ghosts ghosts forever infinite
ghosts forever goes it's no surprise
that gamers have to make tough calls
when it comes to what games do buy
because they're expensive lucky for us
there's like a McDonald's value menu of
sales going on at PlayStation right now
today's playstation store update has
brought with it a new sale to celebrate
golden week holiday period in japan it
offers the usual array of discounts on
ps4 ps3 Vita and PSP games some of which
are particularly good the sale is
available to all playstation network
users with PlayStation Plus subscribers
getting steeper discounts gravity rush
remastered is 18 bucks ha TOEFL
boyfriend for two 55 bucks for
non-subscribers and Yakuza 54 24 bucks
persona for dancing all night thirty
dollars Mega Man fans are gonna go nuts
this week with some of these discounts
including mega man 8 for a dollar fifty
mega man legends for six bucks and mega
man maverick hunter x 44 maybe best of
all is the misadventures of tron bone
for just a dollar 49 that is less than a
double cheese burger at McDonalds yes
that's cheaper than these grumpy cat
stickers i found on amazon go get it
finally all the Xbox news both backwards
compatibility and all the games you get
with gold the list of backwards
compatible games on xbox one grows
pretty substantially today with five new
xbox 360 games being added to a pretty
killer list as revealed by Microsoft's
Major Nelson on Twitter it's an xbox
live arcade heavy selection of games
without any particularly big names
here's the full list you get altered
beast the cave comix zone Double Dragon
neon Ghostbusters sanctum of slime not
to be confused with ghostbusters rectum
of rhyme if you already own or decide to
buy these games they just show up and
you're ready to download area of the my
games and apps section of your xbox one
pretty easy now let's talk about games
of gold line up for Xbox one you get
defense grid 2 costume quest to and
sunset overdrive xbox 360 gets grid 2
and peggle and that's it that's all the
news I have for you today there's no
more I'll probably have some more
tomorrow so check back then see ya have
a good day
you